I actually find it incredibly  frustrating that we have the most  sophisticated tools ever offered to a  couple generations of artists and we use  it to imitate a photograph I think that  the future of our medium is to use it to  express what I get such a thrill out of  every time I walk into a children's book  store and see thousands of books by oil  painters and acrylic painters and every  one of them has a different style and a  different palette in a different shape  language and so I actually get very  frustrated with the sort of crazy  photo-real drive this industry has had  for 30 years and gets so excited when I  see something like the the beautiful  square-jawed characters and up or the  fanciful crazy characters in Madagascar  who are designed to have a strong unique  and interesting and artful and narrative  shape as opposed to G how close can we  get into a photograph  you